and I think you know Joe and I kind of
agree a lot on these things in fact I
think Joe goes further than I do on the
Trump stuff like he said he would rather
vote for Trump I was like I don't even
get that far I said like I understand
but I haven't made any part commitments
or anything man every day goes by I feel
this I mean I said it well you're a note
for him I did I said it the more every
single day I feel more and more
confident that decision yeah but here
here's why I wouldn't go that far is
because Joe Biden I don't think is gonna
be the nominee well I should say so then
I'm leaning slightly towards them
pulling him out if they pull him out
there's no reason why the other people
that have already backed down shouldn't
be the ones that it would be a NAS it
won't be me exactly and I know like
maybe Cuomo I don't like that I do this
it's essential you know capabilities I I
don't know what they're gonna do man
yeah I don't because it's six months out
even if they got rid of Biden we're
gonna do they're gonna introduce the
country to Andrew Cuomo there was one
article that said a Hillary Clinton
Barack Obama ticket and I threw up on my
mouth a little bit like no way that's
never gonna happen but here's what I'm
saying man I'm I'm I'm fairly confident
like if Joe well so no no I should put
that way I should say I'm leaning
slightly towards them pulling out Joe
Biden like there's a tons of articles
popping up saying get rid of them
there's tons of calls from people saying
it's time for Plan B right well
Cassandra Fairbanks released that
article that there's this I don't know
some sort of committee to get Michelle
Obama on the VP on the VP well it's a
it's like a super PAC or something yeah
okay so they're gonna try to get her to
do it right I said and people were like
oh please to Michelle Obama will never
do it and it's like I I don't know I'm
not saying it's a greater than chance
probability I'm just saying like you
know if I'm thinking it they've been
thinking it for the past few weeks or
months nobody thought Joe Biden was ever
gonna weigh that dude his sunsetting I
did it he really is so look yeah every
everything they've complained about
Trump like Biden is worse they say like
oh but Donald Trump has talked about
abusing women
dude there's video footage of Biden
abusing whoa whoa whoa I'm sorry no no
no women little girls and that is a big
difference to me
I mean my goodness they're both bad but
he's making little girls creeped out
yeah
if I wasn't I can't understand the
fathers and every single one of those
videos looking at it like it's Joe Biden
I guess it's okay nah like what is going
on like man Ted Cruz I don't like button
yeah like Ted Cruz trying to kiss a baby
I think or something I don't like that
either but yeah but so my violence girls
man but I'm gonna address this right
it's it's a common thing to like you
know kiss babies and shake hands okay
Joe Biden's not doing that now right so
there's like there's cookies videos of
tons of laughing to them with his hands
dude there's videos of him with like a
little thing them and he's like broking
their chests and stuff dude yes I can't
stand it it's so you place lecherous old
Joe next to trump and I got a potty
mouth Trump versus the dude on camera
doing these things to an omelet I don't
like either of them to be honest well
there's that Andrew shelter think his
name is the comedian okay he did this
bit
Rogen actually posted it and he says
something like the reason Joe Biden's be
president is that he's the real deal
look Donald Trump talks about grabbing
women Joe Biden actually did it and then
but then he stops and it's over and goes
allegedly but I'll put it this way
that's good
I'm not 100% but I absolutely would lean
towards voting for Trump if Biden was on
the ticket and it's because I think it
is reckless I think it is is horrifying
and Tara it is irresponsible for them to
put that man in the Oval Office and yeah
now I understand like they could get a
VP who would potentially be doing most
of the work but that feels like
subversion yeah and I don't I still
don't trust the idea of me putting my
name behind someone like Biden nah sorry
man not gonna happen so I really one of
the things that stops me from going all
the way and saying like I would have
solely vote for Trump in that capacity
is that I don't like the idea of voting
for the lesser of two evils I 100 100
percent agree with you I actually
actually think there's a in a lot of
ways Trump is better than a lot of the
presidents we've had in a long time and
go ah but I think men like his is he's
got an erratic sporadic irrational
irrational is the wrong word impulsive
yeah and so it's like well I certainly
like that that's why I look there's a
lot of presidents might have been like
never
happen like McCain Obama I'm like mm-hmm
I would before any of those people with
trumpets like there's a lot of things I
can see wrong with them but I also know
the media lied about almost everything
and that makes it really really hard for
the left to argue why Trump should never
be president right it's like dude listen
I've been reading the news all day every
day since the man got elected and it's
been life their lie after lie I don't
know why I should believe you anymore
so when they come out and they say stuff
like there was this a segment the
Washington Post put out where it said
like here's seven times Trump lied about
you know kovat or something one of the
segments shows him going you know some
people are saying that it might go away
in April with the heat and then it
freezes and then the next bit is a
reporter saying mr. president you said
it would go away and April's I never
said that and they're like ah he lied
and I'm like he didn't he said some
people think right now you want to play
semantics and say oh no no no but that
was him asserting it who were these some
people no no a lot of people online were
saying that
yeah like the whole open by Easter thing
he was like I would love to have the
economy over my Easter it would be great
if we can have everything running by
Easter and they're like you said that
you your plan was the right answer and
he's like I said I wanted to do like a
fiddle
he like I think he knows this too like
he says things that aren't absolute like
he's toying with the idea but it's not
even that right you remember Jim do you
know about what happened with the Shinzo
Abe a of Japan and the koi fish pond no
what is it so a video goes viral of a
camera zooming in on Trump and you know
Trump and Shinzo Abe a were taking
little bits of fish food and tossing it
to the pond right okay then also in the
camera zooms in on Trump and it shows
him dumped the whole the whole thing of
food into the water okay and boy did the
internet go go wild and they were like
oh this man is such an embarrassment
can't believe you would do that he just
dumped all of the food in yeah you're
supposed to do a little bit and then the
real footage got released and guess what
happened Shinzo Abe a through all the
foot food in Trump look that I'm
shrugged and then did the same thing
Trump was taking the cue of the the
Prime Minister of Japan showing him and
you have the Covington kids you know
about that race the cup you know the
company now I don't tell me about that
there were a field trip of kids standing
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial
oh this video goes viral the Native
American banging drum when I first got
sent that video
I was watching and I'd everyone saying
things to me you like do did you see
this do you see this Tim you see this
and I watched it I'm like I don't know
what I'm looking at right I'm like so
why should I be upset and they were like
dude look at that kids doing I'm like is
he doing he was like almost in shock
that they were standing in front of him
I remember seeing his face it was just
kind of he was just like like what do I
do
right what I was being myself I was
being told they were like he got in the
face of the Native American and started
smugly and I was like there's that's not
the video right you didn't send me a
video the kid walk up to native maybe
send me a video of like two people
staying in front of each other right but
the media went nuts yeah and now they're
getting sued
CNN settled so this is the problem right
there are things that I find
disagreeable to president me but at this
point I got to say there's a big
motivating factor like an fu factor of
like I am so sick of being insulted and
lied to ya every single day it's true
and so you know what it's like man when
Donald Trump won I laughed a hearty
laugh yeah because it was comeuppance
for the Democrats and how they screwed
over Bernie yeah and I was I was pissed
I was like you get what you deserve like
this is what this is the game you played
and you lose because of it I couldn't
believe it happened now I'm kind of like
you know what man if they really want to
put up Biden if this is the game they
want to play they deserve to lose and I
will laugh again admittedly I will laugh
if Biden wins too because that's just
like it's an equally funny thing well
it's because you know a lot of people
were saying that the Donald Trump vote
was the chaos vote really yeah they were
like a vote for Trump is to burn it all
down so there are a lot of like there
are a lot of left like I don't I don't
probably it was a huge number but there
I knew some like antiva type people who
are like definitely voting for Trump
because they thought Trump was the
fastest path towards everything
collapsing then the economy roars
everything's better right but I'll tell
you what man if you really want to see
things collapse vote for Biden yeah like
the vibe I get he's gonna he's gonna
like go into a meeting with you know
like Iran and he's gonna be sleeping and
snoring and they're gonna be like
shrugging and then one guy's gonna walk
over with a contract for some ridiculous
terms like lifting all sanctions yeah
giving them bailouts and then they're
gonna there would be like mr. president
you were just taught to sign any goes
right over here and then he just signs
it right and falls asleep again yeah his
tweets are all articulate and like long
and I'm like I want to see him say
any one of these tweets I think Nick won
I don't care what one it is and just
read it to me to read your own tweet
what did you say you know and I know
it's funny when when they asked Trump
the other day and they're like Joe Biden
we didn't know he didn't dude it's it's
the prospect of a Biden presidency is
scary yeah because David that like his
proponents have even said the same thing
it's a placeholder candidacy mm-hmm a
one-term president it's funny he
actually said this Biden did yeah he
said something like what exactly did he
say remember he said he was like I'll be
a one-term president and then he walked
back like no no that's not what I meant
so he said something like I want to hold
the place for somebody like the mayor
Pete's of the world mm-hmm I really want
to like set the stage and I don't expect
to be here for that long oh dude I'm
laughing but I said you know I really I
really actually feel bad because there
was a when he was doing the micro
Brzezinski interview did you watch that
and so man she she went she did she
didn't follow I saw the clips of this
you think Oh easy on him
no she felt so bad for Biden yes when
someone just said that I'm roasting an
old man it's like yeah he's an old man
he shouldn't be on running for president
it's not about roasting him it's about
the people who are propping him up and
to make that's why still making the
choice to run though I know but come on
what a two-year-old takes it makes the
choice to don't work an electrical
outlet we don't blame the two-year-old
so like bad parenting so he's a
two-year-old like yeah dude yeah clearly
out of his mind and he's sitting there
mumbling and sputtering he can't speak
and they keep doing it this to him or a
reason why I don't want to vote for this
man right listen on that micro Burzynski
interview it was so sad this confused
disheveled old man mm-hmm just sitting
there like why are you yelling at me
yeah what's happening I don't understand
I'm like come on man I can't come up
with an excuse fast enough it's not like
it's about like you just want something
no no you took a man who is who was like
listen I'd be willing to bet that if he
had to stand trial the the opposing
legal team would easily argue he's not
fit to stand trial okay he's not there
they'd be I listen to him speak and he'd
be like you know
didn't well the thing with me and they'd
be like this man is clearly not fit to
testify mm-hmm
if they put him on MSNBC and put him in
front of his woman who actually asked
him some tough questions yeah she said
something like so we're supposed to
believe all went believe all women
except until it's you and it's like she
got she kind of smacked him out a little
bit got a huge point she could have she
could have been tougher on him but she
was pretty tough yeah and it this had
this look on his face tougher he would
have broke he had this look on his face
where he was like you know just just
like his brow bone down confused like I
don't understand what's happening you
know like what's happening right now and
I'm like you know what man we're humans
we are young and vulnerable then we
become teenagers young adults adults
we're capable of sustaining ourselves
yeah and then once we get older we look
to our families and we look to varying
degrees of our society to help it
helping us out as we as we we sunset we
live lives of a life of a bell curve
you know Joe Biden is clearly well
beyond his prime like oh yeah that's an
understatement well beyond he's like
they're they're stretching what little
bit he has left beyond where he should
even be going mm-hmm
um it makes me sick to see what they put
that guy through you know I get it he's
sitting there being like I want to do
this Obama said Joe you don't have to do
this there there there you know what it
is I wondered what that meant you don't
have to do this way what do you mean
running for president is like a powerful
statement yeah it's an aspirational goal
yeah you shouldn't you should want to be
President at least what does it mean you
don't have to do this you say like you
say that to somebody who's like about to
run to a burning building to save a life
like you don't have to do this yeah
exactly
it was it was Joe but that's it
sacrificial lamb they you know a lot of
people felt this way there's a lot of
posts on social media saying things like
and I agree with this that he's just a
holdover candidate they know he won't
win yeah and they don't want to waste a
bootie judge they don't want they don't
want to waste their actually younger
candidates who might win next in the
next cycle because it's anyone's game
next time right and so they know chump
will be a trough a trough battle Trump
Trump will be a tough battle that's how
tough it is he deserves know own word so
they're like you know what that's rough
they're like you know what
is done yeah we don't want to waste any
of our young more energetic candidates
yeah throwout Biden he'll lose we won't
go to waste anybody and burn them in the
press there that makes a lot of sense to
me yeah net that makes total sense
that's not there's no chance I'm gonna
make big huge pot of popcorn for when
they go debate each other
it'll never I can I seriously people
were asking me on atom cast that we
should do a live stream we can't no I
know
yeah they shut everybody down that's
fine Crowder did it with CNN some it's
tough though you know they they didn't
get it they didn't stream CNN they
streamed straight from the White House
and I don't know that guys they still
they still go after people but it worked
you did it so what happens is when the
White House or c-span or some other
nonprofit or public entity those dream
yeah
CNN and other outlets pick it up okay
and then argue that because the audio
and video matches their content they
strike you down and then you can't live
stream for two that's ridiculous yep
yeah you know you know you know Luke
Luke really yeah so Luke did an
interview this is years ago this is like
2012 I think al Jazeera uh-huh took his
footage under fair use okay ran a
segment and then copyright claimed his
video which was uploaded first and
YouTube took it down what yeah and they
took his money that's talked about
messaging Oh yikes
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you